sé que puedo contar contigo para
conseguir que Rusia vuelva a entrar en
razón y llevar a todos a la mesa de
negociaciones se lo ha dicho esta tarde
el presidente francés Emmanuel macron a
su homólogo chino simpín en los
prolegómenos de su reunión el gran
palacio del pueblo sí ha contestado que
espera que las negociaciones empiecen lo
antes posible y se pueda encontrar una
solución política para una seguridad
europea equilibrada efectiva y
sostenible el foco de la reunión como ya
se esperaba está en Ucrania también se
esperaba que ambos subrayaran la
necesidad de acabar con la guerra pero
en los matices de los discursos se
intuyen las diferencias sobre cómo
conseguirlas según macron la solución
tiene que respetar la carta de las
Naciones Unidas y como ya repetido la
Unión Europea en numerosas ocasiones
solo el plan de paz propuesto por
Ucrania cumple ese requisito no lo
cumple en cambio el plan de paz chino si
ha aplaudido la defensa francesa de un
mundo multipolar en lo que supone la
enésima crítica a la hegemonía de
Estados Unidos macron es una de las
voces más pragmáticas de Europa defiende
una vía alternativa a la hostilidad de
Washington y acentúa la necesidad de
incrementar el comercio con china en sus
viajes está acompañado de la jefa De la
comisión Úrsula fonderlayer
representante de la línea más dura y
alineada con Estados Unidos
recientemente exigió a Europa que se
blinde frente a las compañías
tecnológicas chinas en sectores
sensibles y acentúe la autosuficiencia
En aquellos dominados por Pekín